my name's Nick zitzmann and I work on
the front ends to some of our web
services like Wolfram Alpha and Wolfram
cloud and I'm here to talk to you today
about the Wolfram cloud app now those of
you who are at last year's tech
conference you may have seen in the
keynote address Stephen gave you a very
brief sneaky peak of the cloud app which
was in development at the time and we
launch the app last April to coincide
with the launch of the Apple watch it
was an Apple watch launch app and today
I would like to go over some of the
things related to Wolfram clouds like
the system requirements what you can do
with the app what you can't do with the
app I'm going to give a live demo of the
app and in the end I'll show you how you
can get your own copy so here are the
system requirements first of all you
need Wolfram cloud or private cloud
account you don't need a paid account
you can use a free account you can still
sign in views do things deploy things
with the app if you have a free account
if you have a private cloud account if
your organization owns a private cloud
then you can also use the app to access
the your private cloud server and you
need an iOS device we require Iowa seven
or later but that's for requirement will
be up to iOS 8 or later real soon now we
don't have an android version of the app
yet and we strongly recommend that you
use the app on a device that has two
gigabytes or more physical memory such
as the ipad air 2 and the iphone 6s
it'll also work on a device with one
gigabyte of memory which is the ipad 3
the for the original ipad air ipad mini
2 3 and 4 and the iphone 5 and 6 and the
ipod touch 6 we really don't recommend
that you use the device the app on an
iOS device with less than a gigabyte of
RAM that includes the iphone 4s the ipad
2 ipod touch 5 and the original
had many and the reason for that is
because the front end has a very large
memory requirement and those devices
that I listed off have only half a gig
of memory inside them and that is not
good because the Apple eat up all of
your available memory and the OS will
step in and mercy kill the app now iOS
supports virtual memory every computer
operating system now supports virtual
memory but what it doesn't support is it
doesn't support swap so once the system
starts running out of memory starts
mercy killing applications including the
front one most one none of these devices
are in production anymore you can still
use the app on the device but you should
only use it to manage files that are not
notebooks now you might want an Apple
watch if you have the iphone version of
the app you can and you have an Apple
watch you can view your deployments on
the cloud on your Apple watch and I'll
go into how you can do that a little bit
later we will not run your battery all
the way through because the kernel runs
on the cloud side so if you run a
particularly large evaluation we're not
going to blow through all your batteries
here are some of the things that you can
do with the cloud app you can connect to
our cloud or your organization's private
cloud you can browse files and folders
in the cloud space you can create new
notebooks if your plan allows you to
create new notebooks you can edit your
existing notebooks inside our JavaScript
front and anything that you can do in
the cloud on your web desktop web
browser will also work inside the app
you can fill out instant API is instant
web forms you can magnify what you're
looking at you can copy and paste text
from other iOS applications you will be
able to copy and paste images as well in
the next version of the app and I will
show you that as well you can insert
images from the camera or a photo
gallery into
book or a web form you can rename and
delete your cloud objects and you can
also use the app to browse the online
we're from documentation there are some
things you cannot do in the cloud app
you cannot currently create new folders
you can't move objects between folders
quite yet you cannot create or view
scheduled tasks you cannot use the app
to share files with other users like you
could from the desktop you cannot resize
2d objects and that is actually due to a
bug and we know about this and we're
working on it likewise you should also
be able to rotate 3d objects but due to
another bug that we are currently
working on you can't do that yet
obviously we have no mobile system
modeler so that's not going to work and
if you have a connected device that's
yeah you can't read or write directly
from a connected device like an arduino
or something like that you can still
work with indirect sources like data
drop for example so let's take a look
okay you can see that i'm going to start
the app up now and first time it's going
to sign me in now this is your first
time running the app one of the things
after you sign in its you're not seeing
it right now because I've already done
this but we will ask you for your
location permission to ask your location
and the reason we do that is for the
colonel evaluations that might use our
geolocation we can use that information
to give you results that actually works
off your current geolocation if you
don't give us that information that is
fine but any such evaluation is going to
throw your geolocation off to some place
in Kansas somewhere in the middle of
Kansas I think it's the default
geolocation is on the middle of the
continental United States which is
somewhere lower central Kansas in any
case um if you're concerned about
your privacy we do sender in that
information encrypted and the
information is governed according to our
privacy policy and I will show you that
you can touch the hamburger button here
to bring up the master control to
navigate and if i touch my name up here
it's going to show accountant settings
you can see our terms of service privacy
policy by the way this is also where you
press the big red button to sign out so
well i'm here i'm going to create a new
notebook all right now those of you
who've used the desktop front end this
is going to be quite a bit different
looking at mobile front in because a lot
of stuff that would work on the desktop
doesn't work quite well on mobile like
you might notice there's no tongue
button because good luck trying to touch
that so what we have instead is if you
look down at the bottom of the screen
here don't know if you can see that we
have a little pop-out view there which
we internally call the raft and from the
raft you have some commands here you can
create a new cell you can paste content
from other applications and these arrow
buttons up here I'm going to get to
after we create some new cells so I'll
press the new so we're from language
input and here we can do something your
usual iOS keyboard will appear down here
and we just like with the wolfram alpha
app we have a keyboard on top of that
one for doing mathematical and
programming in cells and there's a
button here big button call to evaluate
I'm going to touch that evaluate button
and it will run my evaluation just like
that I don't know if you can see that
you probably can't so we have a feature
here called Meghna font magnification
it's this button here and I am going to
blow that up for you you can probably
see that better from the back there okay
let's do something a little bit more
ambitious and putting two and two
together so what should I do here let's
do as you can see as I type here we have
autocomplete sine of X cosine of Y 2
pounds of X negative PI to positive pi
oops do the same thing for y
close-up valuate and it will run run run
there we are and we can go back in here
and we can make editorial changes if we
want run the evaluation again there we
go one other thing we can do here is
this button in between the AAA button
and this menu button here this is what
the menu button does by the way you can
evaluate rename delete from there this
button here will bring up the
Documentation Center and this will go to
the web and you can browse the war from
documentation from here or you can even
search like okay and you can cancel out
of that and we can go back to where we
were and as you use the app you can go
back and forth between the documentation
and what you were looking at and we will
keep the state the same every time let's
do something more interesting here let
me show you photos so edge effect and
I'm going to insert a photo here it's
this button right above the evaluate
button it's not in the currently
shipping version of the app but it will
be in the next version and I'm going to
take a photo from my photo library can
you see that all right this is His
Majesty the Panther King great great
tycoon of everything that he surveys and
he's sitting there evaluating his
kingdom from high atop Pride Rock and
we're going to close that up now
ironically my cat's name is the edge so
we are going to run HD text here and see
if HD text will actually detect edge yes
it does there is
okay now let's go back to these arrow
buttons down here you can see that Tom
the up arrow button has suddenly become
available this is how we move in between
cells inside the cloud app because it's
not realistic to be expect everybody to
be able to perfectly touch each of these
cell brackets over here on the right
hand side so we can use this to go up
and down and we can also do evaluation
and we can do copy and paste and we can
also close and reopen groups by touching
this button here in the lower left
corner like that okay so I'm going to go
back here but since I haven't saved my
work it's going to remind me to actually
give this object a name if I choose exit
without renaming it's going to be saves
to my unnamed cloud objects folder or I
can actually give it a name hear
something really inspired and you can
see that it appeared in the lower left
corner of the icons down there ok now
but some do something that isn't a form
let's go to deployments instant web
forms here are some web forms that I've
deployed previously and you can view
these and interact with them inside the
application as well this is one I made a
while ago that translates between
English and a crypto language from a
popular video game from 15 years ago
called al bed and let me type something
in here
go directly in praat that's it yeah
that's what we just wrote there in our
bed and now we can press the X button
here to go back to where we were and we
can go back and all right one other
thing I wanted to show you is Apple
watch integration and we can't do this
from the ipad because there is no way to
pear and apple watch with an ipad but we
can do this with iphone so i'm going to
switch devices here again okay so the
way we do i'm sharing with the Apple
watch here is I've got a folder here
called watch apps which has some watch
app deployments both of these were from
Stevens blog post last April with it was
titled something like watch gallery with
some deployments here that can go to
apple watch now you may notice that
there's a new button here on the iphone
version of the app up here in the top
right corner next to the search button I
touched that and it says select objects
to show on your Apple watch I can select
something here and save it and it gets
badged with a little badge down there
now when you get the Wolfram cloud app
for your iPhone and you have a parrot
Apple watch the Wolfram cloud app for
apple watch will automatically be loaded
on to your watch and since I don't have
a camera here I can't actually show you
the app but when you have it running it
will show you all of the items that you
have deployed to your Apple watch in a
state in a watch kit table view and you
can touch any of those objects and it
will show any object in a read-only form
forms won't work but pretty much every
other deployment up to and including
notebooks will work it would look
something like this when you actually
view a file on grab a watch
all right that is what I wanted to show
you with the cloud app now I'm going to
switch back to my desktop alright so
those of you who have an iphone here you
can launch your QR code reader here and
point your QR code reader to the screen
and you can download the app that link
will take you directly to the iTunes
Store and I put the underlying Wolfram
language code to get that barcode image
with the URL up front so I'm not
rickrolling you